well sporting icon tennis legend boris
becker's behind bars after being
sentenced to two and a half years in
prison for hiding millions of dollars in
assets to avoid paying huge debts the
six-time grandson winner was accused of
hiding his wimbledon trophies too when
he was made bankrupt in 2017. one woman
standing by him is his ex-wife lolita
divorced in 2018 but remain on good
terms and lily becker joins me now for
her first interview since the shocking
news of boris going to prison well good
evening to you lily thank you it must be
i mean for the rest of us we're watching
this iconic guy
go to prison it seems a terrible fall
from grace for him
many people will think he deserved it
because of the scale of money which he
was involved in
trying to hide other people will think
it seems quite a severe sense but for
you
and his family and it's a big family and
he's had a complicated life in many ways
but it must be so personal for you
what's happened
i think it's personal for all of us like
you said he said
we have a big family i called us the
original patchwork family in my um in
germany uh we all pulled together his
ex-wife the kids
um his current girlfriend lillian we all
the first thing we did was reach out to
each other yes and
um it's hard because it's public it's
everywhere it's hard because everybody
has an opinion about it rightly so
um and i'm here to to actually show
everybody that he has a bunch of really
strong women behind him and here to not
speak be for for him but to protect him
i mean i mean
it was well known that a while ago you
and his girlfriend lillian had a bit of
a spat you went on social media and had
a bit of a popular but has what's
happened brought you guys close in a
weird way that you both see a guy that
you've had great love for go to prison
absolutely and up until today i'm super
embarrassed and i'm we're going to meet
up pretty soon and i would love to
apologize to her
face-to-face to lillian absolutely she
was the first one to uh reach out to me
uh asked how i was doing how i was
holding up house armor days absolutely i
said thank you um we're doing okay
a-okay as good as it can be then i
called barbara the ex-wife and um it was
just a non-spoken thing it's like right
here we are let's get together and let's
protect this guy the humiliation was
already enough for him to have it done
on air for three weeks long sitting
there not being able to to
well he can't defend himself but as if
you know burris you know you know that
he has pride
and uh to then be sentenced in everybody
immediately having something to say yeah
he deserves it if you don't know what he
deserves
but humiliate your
humiliation that's his opinion when you
heard he was getting a two and a half
year prison center that's a long time
and this is the man who's the father of
yours your son amadeus he's 12 now what
was that moment like for you when you
heard the sentence i completely broke
down i couldn't hear i couldn't believe
what i was hearing because i was
convinced up until the judge made her
verdict that he was going to get off a
little bit lighter than i mean two and a
half years and i had to keep it together
and i did not know how i did it
i i kind of did it thank god my son i
was prepared i kept him out of school he
was upstairs does he don't know what's
happened
i
he does now he did i had to break it
down to him his kids will tell him at
school he'll see it on the internet
right now but there was the thing i had
kept we as a family including boris
millian and the kids we had
by
uh purposely not allowed him or spoke
about the trial or anything and then um
and i didn't have no chance but to break
my heart or actually his heart last
sunday and it's i don't wish this up on
anybody it was
the hardest thing i had to do with the
12 year old to tell him his dad was
going to prison he did he just couldn't
grasp him still can't and it breaks my
heart but it just made me into tiger
mama because i feel now that
i think we've all been through enough as
a family there is a mother involved i'm
not here i'm not asking for sympathy i
don't want it nor would boris want that
i'm asking for empathy i'm asking for
everybody that had an opinion or wanted
to write about him
to please stop you saw boris um just
before he got sentenced yeah
what was his state of mind about this
does he feel the judge did criticize him
for not showing any humility or
accepting he'd done much wrong
do you think as the time came nearer
that boris understood what he'd done and
it was wrong i think boys always knew
what was what was going to happen he
knew from the beginning this is going to
be a tough one it's going to be
worldwide but what do you do in a
situation like that you just go and be
mentally prepared and thank god
his mental health is so strong and he
was probably prepared for these moments
because life at boris is never boring
it's a
headline of the headline and what has
happened to him now i think uh please
allow him to heal behind closed doors
and then do you know how he's getting on
in prison it must be a very different
experience liliana has told me that he's
okay he's fine i mean it's not a
five-star hotel is it like he can be as
good as he can be and what about
his sense of
pride you talked about early does he
feel a sense of shame about what's
happened wouldn't you i think everybody
is and that's why i feel that you know
he's embarrassed you know he's
humiliated he knows that everybody
always had so how is he going to pick
himself up from this
and
the best way he can stay trying to stay
mentally strong focused because it's
just an obstacle in the vote it takes a
pretty extraordinary guy too he is
extraordinary well i was going to say i
mean i've known boris socially and i've
always liked him he's a he's a great
character and he was a wonderful
sportsman i remember when he won women
he was one of the best i mean amazing
he's also always had a magnetic appeal
to women still and here you are a
beautiful woman talking as his ex-wife
very lovingly about him lily and his
girlfriend very beautiful talks lovingly
about him his first ex-wife talks
lovingly about him you're all coming
together
what is it about boris becky that has
that draw to women like you well that's
exactly it it's either you have it or
you don't he has a great charisma he is
a fantastic father a funny guy honest
and you either have that swag or not and
he is if you've met him you know how
charismatic he is you know when you sit
down and he tells a story you are just
glued to him he's got this blue eyes and
it's just a charm and this is how he's
won lots of fans so how will he deal
now lily do you think with the fact he's
now a convicted criminal because he is a
man of pride and when he comes out of
prison it may be in a year a year and a
half whatever it may be he will come out
as a convicted criminal his life will
never be the same again he says who
well he is a convicted he's a convicted
criminal who says his love will never be
the same again for if the people that
are standing by him and which is a lot i
think don't we all of a comeback kid he
yes and i'm going to get
he has
well he's been committed for a crime
well he's going to do a good time for
those who don't those who haven't
followed it he was sentenced to two and
a half years for hiding 3.1 million
dollars in assets to avoid paying debt
so he got into heavy debt and he tried
to hide money which should have been
used to pay it off that was his crime do
you think that the sentence was
justified no i think it's way too high
absolutely i think it's way too hot
should it be a
punishment absolutely
um i think personally obviously i'm
biased i'm i'm you know part of the
background my last name is becca but i
think two and a half in in in
it's heart it's very harsh um but we
knew from the beginning that this this
judge she was not going to take no uh
are you hoping to take amadeus to see
his father
he is dying to see his father i have
just be
i have just taught a 12 year old
that his father is in jail and the
saddest part about it was that i
couldn't break it down because these
kids are now going on youtube they are
going on the internet internet is crew
but he also has a
loving support system around him and um
he's curious
um and i've told him we all make
mistakes you pop i didn't listen to the
law and he's on the naughty step a
bigger one and was the last thing he
said to boris before when he when he
last saw you i honestly i wrote him and
um
i said to him
um see you next weekend if you want if
you want to see a uh or be good
he gave me this and i sent him a heart
and that was it
and you haven't spoken to him since he
went inside no
do you have to go in yourself
uh if if he would want to yes i mean
absolutely with my son hundred percent i
think i need to be holding my hand with
him and of course i'm seeing him dying
to see him
lily i'm very sorry for what's happened
to you and to amadeus it's very tough
for a little boy to see his dad get a
prison i've got a lot of time for boris
i think what he did was wrong i don't
try and justify that in any way nobody
is i don't think anybody is but uh i
hope he's okay uh during his time in
prison i hope he comes out learning his
lessons and that we can get to see him
again and uh the fact that you stand by
him his ex-wife says a lot about his
character yeah so thank you for coming
in thank you for having us appreciate it
well you may have noticed i've still got
lily becker with me and there's a reason
for that because when the interview
ended she suddenly told me actually
we're not divorced i'm still married to
boris
and we have this extraordinary
conversation i said well why don't you
just stay here for a little bit and
we'll just resolve this once and for all
so everyone keeps reporting that you're
divorced you're still his wife you're
you're not divorced very much still his
estranged wife as that may be but we're
still very much married they've been
since we
meant our separate ways do you want to
get divorced
um
why did you ask me that i think it's
boris has said you're the most intense
lover he's ever had in his life uh it
was from the beginning intense it was in
a complete true
love story there is no ifs or not about
it and everybody that knows us knows
this you don't want to divorce him do
you
um that's a why do you do this it's not
that i don't want to get a divorce i
think we should handle our business at
the right time this is not the right
time this is everybody's involved we
will do it right now you're still his
wife and you still love him of course i
do
of course i do we all love him lillian
loves him barbara loves him amadeus
loves him but right now we need to be a
unity and i think this this let's get
divorced or not that that's definitely
on the back burner let's get him sorted
let's get him right let me all get to as
we do right now and then we do it when
it's the right time okay well i wanted
to keep you here to set the record
straight so there we have it a world
exclusive boris park is not divorced
from lily they're still married
uh he's
talked about your crazy love i can see a
bit of crazy love coming back from you
to him so who the hell knows how this
all washes up but it's it's fascinating
and thank you for staying and clarifying
that of course i think that's important
too
good to see